pitcher that they will face mike krucco
is giants right-hander kevin gausman
kevin gausman making start number 27
12 and 5 on the year with a 2 4 9 era
peterson goes down swinging against the
splitter wow
that was a great one well always so
important for him to establish that that
split and this is as good as he can
throw it that thing starts out at the
belt and drops down the dirt if he gets
that consistently tonight that'll be a
great sign for the giants
got him
and that is nasty
that's as good a start to the game with
a split that we've seen him have in a
long time long time so here's yelich
with two down and nobody on the one-two
pitch splatters struck him out swinging
a great first inning and gosman gets
three straight strikeouts on the
splitter and now brad anderson like
gausman likes to go quick yeah to keep
that pace going don't give hitters the
time to sort of think and read your body
language have an idea where you're going
posey
a brewer killer
350 career batting average
on the ground
over to second peterson over to first
nicely turned double play and the bases
are loaded with nobody out a dangerous
hitter coming to the plate for the
brewers roddy telez
he hits it the other way and it's caught
at third wilmer flores
got over there to make the play big
first out
telez is the first out of the second
inning now lorenzo kane five for nine
lifetime against gausman bases loaded
pitch line drive base hit right field
one run scores here comes narvaez
towards the plate the throw from bryant
offline it's two-nothing milwaukee on a
two-run single by lorenzo kane so now
anderson
anderson just a little dribbler maria's
breaking for the plate the tag he is out
at home plate
kevin gausman nice play and a great tag
from posey that
is an athletic play
there's nothing easy about this play
peterson to right center bryant is there
for the catch and now number three
there's brandon crawford
hits anderson
ricochets out into left field
yellows will hustle it in boy anderson
turned quickly that hit him right on the
left shoulder it looked like and that
was scary that was right at his head it
looks like he's gonna stay in and this
is a great sign two men are on two
singles to start it slater
and that's into right center field
garcia makes the catch
and both runners were halfway so they
both retreat an opportunity to get out
of this inning with no damage if you can
get tyro estrada then you get the
pitcher spot coming up
estrada
off the end of the bat yellets will make
the play for out number two
strike three called right down the
middle with a fastball and the inning is
over
for milwaukee
got it swinging with the split
so now garcia garcia a big hitter in
this game
got him swinging fastball strike three
five strikeouts for gaza and all swing
and miss strike threes two down for
narvaez
runner going swinging to miss the tag he
is out at second
that was all posing
brett anderson
is out went to the clubhouse and that
means hunter strickland is called to the
pin two down brian goes to third out
number two here's posey little line
driving the left right into the tracks
of yelich who's there to squeeze it for
the third and final out
hunter strickland trying to give the
brewers two innings tonight coming in
for the injured brett anderson and he's
back out there for the fourth
wilmer flores brandon crawford and
austin slater coming up flores will
start
pop-up
it
territory
gonna stay playable narvaez has got it
for out number one here's the o2 to
crawford
chopper to first fielded on two hops by
telez and he'll step on the bank to take
care of crawford and two quick outs the
1-2
and he got him right on the corner
slater strikes out
lost three in a row right now coming
into this game they are trailing
two-nothing in the fifth inning
right up the middle crawford
freezing kane and throwing out peterson
at first
[Applause]
gosman throws and that one is lying to
short and caught by crawford
while leaning down and striding to his
left he picked it clean
there's justin topah just called up
hard-throwing right-hander a couple of
games with the brewers this year
swinging in the miss he struck him out
97 mile an hour fastball in the outside
corner dickerson
right center field
into the gap
that will go through
dickerson has scored
and bryant will stop at second with an
rbi double
the giants first run of the game and
it's 2-1 milwaukee so now buster he's
due
right along the first base line of fair
ball
bring it around third he scores the
tying run and belt goes to third but it
worked beautifully and it's two to two
now ustremski left against left
in a spot where a base hit with slater's
speed to the outfield would almost
certainly put the giants ahead struck
him out looking from a breaking ball
right down the middle
yes stremski could do nothing but stare
at it two on two out and a two ball two
strike count tie game seventh inning
and peterson in the left field of base
hit
the brewers will take the lead as kane
scores
and jace peterson continues to impress
big hit two out two strike rbi single
and it's three to two milwaukee so now
the bases are loaded for yelich
ground ball to second
estrada has it
over the first for the hour lorenzo kane
here's the pitch to him
kane rips one towards left
back at the warning track at the wall
it's off the top of the fence and did it
stay in play it did
lorenzo kane is going to end up at
second base
and the brewers are going to take
another look at this one here's the call
home run
lorenzo kane will circle him
and now the brewers threaten here with
nobody out two men on
adamus
hits one hard into left field
rough over to pick it up one run is zen
wong
and willy adams
with a double
so two strikeouts and it's brandon belt
here he comes and a swing and a miss he
struck him out
josh hader closes it down again
and the brewers win
[Applause]